hi it's matthew martin from details and
earlier today we saw the gucci
collection free to open the show with a
bunch of really beautiful light blue
pieces and i thought this was a really
refreshing color for fall it was really
soft and more relaxed than what she's
known for and i really like the new
direction and you know overall i really
thought that there was a nice simplicity
to the show and i thought the pieces
were really easy but still had all the
great gucci tailoring and attention to
detail that they're known for there was
a lot of really rich traditional type of
english fabrics like houndstooth window
panes and glen plaid but you know
playing with the proportions and making
them a little bit more fitted and
skinnier i thought was a really
interesting way to sort of modernize
what is thought of as more of a
traditional type of suiting i love that
there was this whole like black on black
on black passage it was really nice i
mean it's very gucci it's very sexy but
i also like that it was really
approachable and it wasn't out of the
range of possibility for any guy to
relate to to close up the show frida
designed these really cool gray tuxedos
and they were made of what looked like a
dave fabric they were tweety looking
they were almost like pound toothy and
it was a really i think cool new way of
dressing for evening that any guy can
stand behind we still have plenty more
videos from milan so check out
details.com and you can always follow me
on instagram and twitter at detailsmap